hey  [Music]  danielle  hey how you doing  i  am here  representing all things purple  to tell you  that you are  our sophia  yep that's oprah surprising danielle  brooks who will be playing sofia in the  upcoming musical adaptation of the color  purple a role previously played by oprah  herself oh my life i had to fight her  now back as a producer on the film oprah  just had to surprise her newest cast  member who is joining the star set of  roster including ali bailey taraji p  henson coleman domingo corey hawkins her  and fantasia taylor who starred in the  broadway adaptation alongside danielle  herself and since the new film is going  to be based on that tony award-winning  musical we know there is no one better  to bring it to the big screen i'm so  happy to pass whatever baton from  35 almost 40 years ago  to you  and i know you're gonna kill it i saw  this  [Music]  yes sofia  [Music]